yeah do things like sell merch or like
that's a good idea like pay people off
fairly so that they want to stay around
longer
[Music]
so there's a woman in Florida who got
the text of a [__] lifetime what what
did they say Hey you won a million
dollars
no because that would seem that would
seem ridiculous this one that would
never happen it's more this one's like
holy [__] this is actually gonna change
my life so she gets a text
and it says that they won
um that the people on the other end won
a 473 million dollar Powerball lottery
jackpot in 2022. and they were donating
90 000 to 50 random individuals wow oh
yeah and then and then this person was
one of the lucky 50s what does she have
to do in return okay I'll give her
social security number give her no
that's a weird first thing to ask it's
even easier or ACH they just needed to
get her credit card information so that
they could make sure to make the
transfer to her credit card yeah yeah
they're gonna put it into a credit
that's how they do it because they need
to cover transfer fees taxes IRS charges
but just in case it doesn't go through
let me have your social security number
yeah she'll have a four digit credit
score and ASL Bart made a pre-read this
article I don't know how he knows all
that you remember like a few years back
somebody had won the Powerball and then
a person immediately made a fake IG
account of them and said they were
giving away money oh that's a good
hustle and it really exposed how many of
your friends are [__] idiots yeah
because they were all tagging you they
were like just tagged five of your
friends I'll give you all money and so
many people that I really thought were
above that I was like damn Hawk tattoo
[Laughter]
it's an investment of a lifetime man he
can't catch anything
I don't know how Powerball looks
I can't be bothered to look it up let's
do more hawk accents so they bled her an
amazing Australia they bled her for a
couple Grand Hawk has been on the show
in like two years by the way
guys build a show for two years
I guess by the time this comes out
it's [__] ridiculous there'll be a
bunch of recipes talk in the comments by
the time this is up oh [__] because he's
your friend fans
that's the best um it's overdue no so
the lottery board issued a press release
acknowledging yes there was a Powerball
jackpot winner who won 473 million
dollars in April but the winner isn't
part of this scam
um this person had thousand dollars
Leech from them so they're trying to
warn people
um you know they're gonna claim to give
you the money
um and then if the Vic if the victim
pays them money first obviously and then
because they have to cover taxes and
expenses and fees and [__] yeah and so
you're like well Chef I'm gonna get like
90 G's what's a thousand dollars it's a
[__] deal of a lifetime damn blows my
mind that people just don't go okay let
me um go to your office and I'll pay in
person
right or like why why do they why do
they just pay that's the weirdest [__]
why do they why do they think that
that's part of it like I would I would
be like okay cool I'll take it on the
90k when I deal with the IRS like
where do you come in yeah like what do I
have to pay for it if I already won
right it doesn't make any sense
where these people just don't question
enough they don't even see on TV it's
like they see on TV the guy holding the
big check is also handing the guy a
little check yeah you can't see his
other hand yeah
you're so distracted by the big double
whoa that one you don't see that one I
want to go to a bank try to catching one
of those oh I don't think it works
really yeah because it doesn't fit in
the ATM huh oh you want to cash it in
the ATM it doesn't fit in the ATM hog
an
sucked up with the smile like that
holding the big check he's like I want
to cash it I'll just throw up right out
of the [__] bag
security guys just pick him up off of
his I want to see judges trying to fill
one of those things at an ATM
go to the bank doors like do you guys
remember trigger happy TV trigger happy
it was a Comedy Central thing where they
um it was [__] hilarious when I was a
kid I thought it was the funniest thing
I ever saw but it was like they get um
like adults in costumes but like a guy's
dressed as a snail and he's like
crawling across the street very slowly
so that people are staying in traffic
like what the [__] is this yeah
I could picture something like that
being on there where a guy's trying to
put a big [__] check into an ATM
machine yeah it's not going through I
don't know why can you help me yeah I
just won this Lottery I'm trying to
deposit it doesn't work where's the big
one yeah where's the big deposits I want
the big checks can I get a really big
bank teller to help me with this big
check so far there's never really been a
situation where somebody won a huge
jackpot and was trying to give it out to
everybody no [__] it was hide that's
never been a fan don't say hi we got
inflation we can't you need every dollar
you can get yeah didn't some catches win
like two Billy yeah like one point
something Bill one point something down
it happened here right in like Monrovia
or something or some [__] yeah Altadena
and then they got the the liquor store
owner got a million and nobody knows who
they are though right not I don't I
think they published the name but I
don't know how does that work when the
liquor store or the store I always heard
of the store gets a bonus sells it yeah
they get the piece yeah they get a bonus
for that it's just a thing that happens
it's to encourage more stores to carry
Lotto
he had a big check too John Robinson
single lump sum 328 million
no no I can't be is it because of after
taxes or is it because multiple people
won oh yeah sometimes it's like three
people will win the jackpot because they
all chose 1.6 bill was the pot dang
imagine getting 300 million dollars
imagine being like I could have had no
[__] billion I mean imagine they had
gratefulness right taxes and fees I hate
this but the curse is all these people
either kill themselves or die early
that's the that's the statistic about
Lotto winners it is a it is a curse
you're not prepared to handle that much
money everyone around you just changes
it's [__] the closest one was a guy that
like I think he like already ran a
business that made like two mil a year
so he survived like longer but everybody
in his family was all [__] up yeah
yeah because that [__] makes you turn
into a [__] thirsty wolf yeah right
so I did the lotto to test me I want to
see my character when I get a 300
million dollars yeah test me too test me
dude yeah maybe a good Lotto winner
well you don't play the lotto because I
think it'd be the shittiest law I winner
in history
what do you think you would do
what do you think I would do probably
buy a bunch of woo
LLY I think you'd put a lot of money in
changes
which is nice they'll probably leave JK
no you wouldn't I actually don't think
he would you wouldn't I don't think he
would no you wouldn't leave Jacob I
would for sure leave JK no you wouldn't
no you wouldn't you guys shouldn't give
us some money would you really leave he
made 100 Mil he told us he's gonna give
us 10 grand each that's it he did say
that yeah that's pretty that's pretty
game probably by JK out for like 40
Grand all right
how much to buy hey how much to buy you
up
dude like twelve dollars 12 Grand 12
Grand I think we talked about what about
you Joe how much to buy you out man how
much 14.
oh okay a true buyout where I probably
10 mil would be decent I put five mil on
the table if I win 320 million that's
nothing to you you're so cheap that's
not the point that's about what you got
if I do you want 320 I'd I charge you
highball them see this is why people
commit suicide when they win friends
like this I want 300 million I'm gonna
[__] send you venmo requests every
day
just small things so what you're saying
is I should send you venmo requests now
every day so if Anthony like say Anthony
wins the Powerball buys out JK what does
he actually get nothing everything in
here you get everything in here you get
your arcade you get to pay another two
three years worth at least I sent debt
there's a time there's a tambourine with
your name on it
I'm sensing a lemon okay you don't want
a matching water gun would have
tampering
would you run anything differently yeah
that's the big question yeah that's a
great question what would I run
differently if I own Jake what would you
change if it belonged to you would there
be more would there be more like turn
the business around so I could start
making money that's a good idea do
things like sell merch or like that's a
good idea like pay people off fairly so
that they want to stay around longer
with your 320 mil you can buy ads from
yourself and then make business you can
make money that way
Ponzi yourself would would you would and
Joe still want to work here if he bought
us out for 10 million I'm leaving
today you know how about work you you're
it's stipulation you have to stay at
this for 24 months
five years middle of five years ago and
there's a nun you buy beers five years
is not compete you're not allowed to uh
participate in anything else that has a
bunch of friends yep well you can't fire
me so hey I'm in
charge I wouldn't fly
I would just have more Nick traps way
more Nick traps I put Nick traps
everywhere I'll just walk in and that
comes up sends me to the ceiling lake
trout for good and I'll try to have a
good attitude the whole time funny but
eventually I'd break probably bring back
Bobby Lee uh Bobby hundreds and film a
couple videos and then make right what
we [__] up or just like and then pick
hand to delete them
or you would you make us read off of a
script it's like so Bobby um Anthony's
not a 911 denier
yeah would we have to bow to your
[__] narrative or would you have a
teleprompter Anthony's just like Steve
read the line okay
Steve's just like Anthony is not a shoe
cobbler I like kids do I have to read
everything you got a noodle salesman
the idea that I got in your head by
Claudio shoe cover is [__] hilarious
[Music]